what's the background to an artwork like
this where does this painting by Picasso
come from could it have been
expropriated by the Nazis looted stolen
every little detail on the back of the
painting is a clue to answer those
questions the back ruin Museum in Berlin
has examined 135 artworks in its
possession the conclusion none of the
works were stolen your voice we don't
want any stolen or illegitimately
acquired goods in our collections even
if it's a major work if it happens it
must be returned so far the Prussian
cultural heritage foundation in Berlin
has returned a total of 350 artworks and
that might just be the tip of the
iceberg it's estimated the Nazis stole
around 600 thousand works of art mostly
from Jewish families and many of them
have still not been returned to their
rightful owners like some of the works
found in 2012 among a stash of 1500
pieces in the Munich apartment of
Cornelius Gurlitt son of the wartime art
dealer Hildebrand Gurlitt pressure is
growing on German lawmakers many think
the process of determining and returning
stolen artworks
takes too long and opposition parties
are demanding more money be spent on
restitution I'm not satisfied with the
situation
because in this case action really
speaks louder than words action has to
be taken and if the museum's don't have
the funds to deal with this then we the
government have to see to it that we
come up with the funds visitors to the
beer crew and museum seem to be on the
same page when it comes to stolen art
Germany has to work much harder to track
down looted works as comic the Gurlitt
case really showed again how much of a
sorry state were in where that is
concerned I think much more work has to
be done God why did you anything
we have to get our house in order on
this well if we don't there's this nasty
feeling and it's something future
generations will always end up being
confronted with of talkin we have for
behind many an artwork there still lies
a gruesome story of Nazi theft
expropriation and injustice